verteidigungsminister thomas steininger
hat partner und unterstützer des
österreichischen bundesheers zu einem
informellen treffen ins
verteidigungsministerium in wien
eingeladen wo ungeschminkt der ist
zustand des bundesheeres thematisiert
worden ist das habe ich seit beginn
meiner amtszeit so gehalten und für mich
präsenten multiplikationsfaktor und
daher verdienen sie sich auch diese
offenheit und ehrlichkeit eine offenheit
und ehrlichkeit die in anbetracht der
finanziell angespannten situation
erforderlich aber nicht
selbstverständlich scheint ich bin sehr
froh dass wir die so offen diskutiert am
ende des österreichischen bundesheers
ich hoffe dass der minister noch
möglichkeiten auf heiße themen
anzusprechen die von einer folge
regierung unbedingt aufgenommen werden
müssen themen wie unter anderem die
möglichkeit zum assistenzeinsatz bei
hochwasser schneekatastrophen und
grenzschutz über den in der
österreichischen verfassung
festgeschriebenen grundauftrag zur
militärischen landesverteidigung bis hin
zum grundwehrdienst themenfelder gibt es
viele minister der parteipolitisch
ungebunden ist kann natürlich einmal
dinge tatsächlich beim namen nennen
das sehen wir natürlich beim bundesheer
bei der budgetären situation
für mich sehr nachvollziehbar
dargestellt wo man glaubt dass man
bittet er ist und wo man eigentlich hin
kommen musste ein finanziell schlecht
ausgestattetes bundesheer ist auch für
österreichs wirtschaft ein thema wir
können nur dann wirklich
erfolgreich exportieren wenn dieses
produkt oder wenn eine leistung
tatsächlich auch in österreich bisher
eingeführt ist es ist relativ klar dass
die meisten staaten versuchen möglichst
nationale produkte für ihren sicher zu
verteidigungsbereich zu verschaffen
und deswegen würde ein potenzieller
käufer immer fragen ist ein dieses gerät
ist diese dienstleistung auch national
eingeführt liebste im bundesheer gibt es
bei der polizei wenn wir da nein sagen
müssten dann geht der potenzielle käufer
davon aus dass das gerät oder die
leistung
nicht den kriterien entspricht die man
sich erwartet und deswegen ist der
nationale also der heimatmarkt ein
unwahrscheinlich wichtiger referenzpunkt
einige der angesprochenen themen sind
auch emotional stark besetzt wie zum
beispiel der zustand mancher
infrastruktur alle relevanten themen
werden sich im zustandsbericht des
österreichischen bundesheers
wiederfinden denn der
verteidigungsminister im september 2009
10 präsentieren wird was es konkret
bringt schon jetzt darüber zu reden sehr
viel weil wir haben daher in sehr viele
multiplikationen sitzen die aus dem
breiten öffentlichen leben kommen und
daher diese botschaften die heute
gebracht wurden natürlich jetzt breit
auch in österreich verteilt